[Applause]
[Music]
look beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
coming in right now where we learned
with the lag but two thousand people
watching what's up two thousand people
you're about to see some really cool
stuff you guys are ready for the wings
the onions yeah right this is Casey's
brother if you guys don't know I'm sure
you all know our YouTube uh I don't know
it's one of those things where I won't
know it so so what happens yeah what the
question is are you a crier today you
will be everyone finds that me some
point in their life but no I'm not I'm
not generally a crier no well we'll see
what happens today
yeah be on the spot now Aaron say hi to
the fans of different case I am Brandon
damn you're looking so good today
oh it's really lagging huh
look at the comments we released now are
using your pocket Wi-Fi no you can
actually combine um it's probably the
plugin
while I'm going on in my cool say hello
how many people Oh beep oh definit like
a many people here
2184 Wow come on down it's like a nice
time
how you guys doing I'm glad you guys
were able to wake up so early to catch
this event it's gonna be mother magical
it's gonna be so nice where you guys
watching everyone says uh so many things
what are the comments name I can't even
see what I'm filming in there look we
can see ourselves so we're gonna go
check out the tea ceremony now guys I
wish I could see what I was filming but
I can't so Jeannie here will be my eyes
see Tara moaning we're going to a
c-termini right now a ceremony because
we don't get the Chinese culture in here
and Tiffani I'm sorry Tiffany do this I
don't I think they're barely learning
how to do it right now
crap you're a read-aloud connection here
okay thank you it's gonna throttle like
there's some limit to how much you can
then if the only wants one video so you
know when you disconnect where you have
like you have two uploads I think my
work here live stream line you think
it's gonna crowd up that Wi-Fi it made a
thousand people one yeah I mean we don't
need Wi-Fi pocket it's live soon do you
do you see a restroom I am I'm watching
you have Wi-Fi now on some other network
but then I have like them still we have
up on your stream or your your Wi-Fi
oh okay on its it's not there I'm one
live stream other you see why she made a
password stuff in case capital T
including two and ever since yeah
hopefully there is connection excuse me
[Music]
you don't like this is like a limit
right here it's um it's probably on a
throttle because I think my one only has
women of three gigs and they want to run
this for five hours
rest in peace that leg just like 3000
people though who listen watching this
right now four thousand
[Music]
[Music]
who's that aren't you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
means duty sir Matthew right oh you
crying Cristina no I'm not yet not yet
we have a long way to go on YouTube
everyone part NGO is here yeah I was in
charge getting him here so they're not
missing a little bit what else you think
because I know cuz uh and you can do
anything
[Music]
oh well your angles good acting on the
phone did you search it on the phone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah not really no one is interested
Apple is
[Music]
almost 7,000 viewers I can't see it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sorry guys we can go any closer because
the internet connection was gonna cut
out if we go any closer so um this might
be as close as we can get for the chief
ceremony but you know for the other
stuff we'll be close to her guys don't
worry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
second guys enjoying the wedding so far
can I see myself
mr. second like oh thank you thank you
Michael they love you I'm so tired
you're too tired thank you for all of
you who are watching right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah I met you on the video when you
guys were playing the tone oh yeah I
mean okay seeing through the phone
school together and then we moved out to
LA together we played together out here
flight yeah II think you finally met tip
and then they went that way or third and
I'm the girl in him
moved in with her so we Howard we're all
can I get a eliminate okay see I make
everybody cry with my fish yes it was
very hard
I love it hey I never fried it I didn't
know I'm supposed to do something like
that bye it came from my heart I don't
even know you either and I'm glad it
came from your heart and I'm glad it
wasn't rehearse no I wasn't rehearse
let me see the comments
Wow it's a lot of people watching 5,000
5,000 people Facebook set week with me a
good news message not me to talk about 7
to 10 minutes assault upon mafia
[Music]
most people will oh sure I'm also
there's no vehicle when I Scott they're
winning I've been winning do I play you
can bet there aren't you go but she says
[Music]
I can persuade that bucket
[Music]
can I have another lemonade and can I
put some like this in there too yes I
like it
[Music]
so is it not what's going on when we
complete they're all gonna see us again
yeah yeah I think so here is hey Michael
is back notice me Michael Michael you're
doing great
Michael Michael getting so many lemon
things 5,000 people
Michael you playing hookers how do they
know about that
no they tell me Michael turn on dollars
in the red light district their mission
we have an Christine video of that
released today
Jim Barton geo go check it out on our
Channel not started yet okay what are
the French guys saying we don't know I
think we I can't read
Oh 6000 Wow well we got six thousand
people now there's no way to read any of
that no I saw oh man I'm really hungry
I just hi guys I see you look beautiful
we're starting hasty oh my god jessica
is love love it I can't read that way
how fresh hookers they're great notice
me Gina
[Laughter]
these commas are insane yeah holy crap
last person in the comment gets $50 from
Michael oh oh the last person the very
last person yeah oh yeah we should be
sitting down so we're gonna move so
we're gonna move you guys to the
ceremony now it's not gonna start right
now but soon let's go soon the doors in
the building
I know are you guys ready for the
ceremony
anywhere so if I want to sit in the very
front is that cool all right if the if
the fans want to sit in there very fun
they can alright this is for you guys in
the very front so I get the right angle
well were they are they gonna stand
right here going over yeah it's a lot
better now I think the connection is
closed early yeah oh okay there was this
sound
yeah there's down you guys getting a
front row seat alright so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for this wedding it's gonna be
very quick very simple straight to the
point
parties very small so just understand
that understand that everybody hears KC
first introduced me to Tiffany and she
kept on going through these changes or I
just couldn't recognize her of course on
Gia's glasses the third time razors
makeup
I just couldn't recognize you seen equal
awesome so much over the years they
don't it's kind of representative of
what we see here today since I first met
you when I first met case yeah San Diego
Film Festival where he was 30 pounds
heavier with long hair not a lot of
grease you guys transform